حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
نبداها من تداعيات مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه في
نيويورك في سابقه تاريخيه لم تحدث لاي
رئيس امريكي سابقا او حالي ويبدو ان ترامب
اول المستفيدين سياسيا مما حدث حيث اعلنت
حملته الانتخابيه جمع عشره ملايين دولار
منذ اعلاني لائحه اتهامه
[موسيقى]
لم اعتقد ابدا ان شيئا كهذا يمكن ان يحدث
في الولايات المتحده جريمه الوحيده هي
الدفاع عن البلاد ضد من يحاول تدميرها كما
تذكرون الديمقراطيون تجسسوا على حمله
الانتخابيه منذ البدايه وحاولوا النيل مني
بتحقيقات زائفه لا اساس لها من الصحه
وهاجموني بشكل شخصي
القضيه المرفوعه ضد هدفها التاثير على
انتخابات 2024
عرضنا طواعيه على مكتب التحقيقات الاطلاع
على الوثائق السريه التي كانت في منزلي في
مارلاجو واستعادتها هذه الوثائق كانت
بحوزه بشكل قانوني احضرتها خلال فتره
كرئيس وبعلم الجميع وهذا امر فعله كل رئيس
امريكي سبقني وكنت اتعامل بحسن نيه الى ان
هاجم الاف بي اي منزلي هذا يبرهن ان
النظام القضائي الامريكي فقد قانونيته
وانهم يحاولون سرقه الانتخابات